Bevor wir zu den Funktionen kommen, möchte ich davor noch was anderes machen
und das ist das Input unter die While-Schleifen.
Und dann gehen wir zu den Funktionen über.
Zu den Inputs ist so, wir haben bis jetzt kennengelernt, okay, man kann Print schreiben,
man kann addieren, subtrahieren und so weiter und so fort.
Aber was, wenn ich möchte, dass mein Programm den Benutzer fragt, ob er mir einen Input gibt.
Das heißt, da kommt dann so ein tolles Fragefenster auf und sagt, okay, schreibt mir den Wert rein,
damit ich mit dem Wert was anfangen kann.
Und das Ganze können wir eben mit diesem Input machen, das schaut dann so aus mit dem Code.
Das heißt, wir haben hier unsere Variable
und dann haben wir diese Input-Funktion.
Und da können wir dann noch die Frage reinstellen oder einen Text hinzufügen.
Das ist aber optional, also das muss man gar nicht machen.
Und dann sobald der User was reingeschrieben hat und dann Enter drückt,
dann wird das in dieser Variable gespeichert
und dann können wir diese Variable, also diesen Text, den wir da reingeschrieben haben, verwenden.
Ich kann das kurz herzeigen.
Dann noch mal eine Reite oben drauf.
Machen wir hier.
Wenn man das bei ihr erwischt, was du dir Code machst,
sagen wir Name, Input.
Also hier als Beispiel, wenn ich nichts reinschreib.
Dann seht ihr hier ganz oben,
kommt diese Eingabe-Leiste hier
und da könnt ihr jetzt was reinschreiben.
Dann werden wir uns das dann anschauen.
Dann wird dieser Wert hier als String wichtig.
Da kommt immer als Ergebnis ein String raus,
wird dann in diese Variable gespeichert
und dann können wir damit was anfangen.
Wie wichtig, das ist ein String,
weil es kann auch Probleme bereiten.
Stellt euch vor, der User ist ein bisschen unhandlich mit der Zastatur
und schreibt dir zum Beispiel davor noch ein Leerzeichen rein
oder keine Ahnung was.
Oder wie gesagt, das ist ja auch ein String.
Das heißt, wenn der dann eine Zahl reinschreibt,
dann ist das immer noch ein String.
Dann kann man da ein paar Sachen machen.
Also wir haben ja dann diesen Wert hier
in dieser Variable Name gespeichert
und sagen wir, ich fühle das noch mal aus.
Und ich mache da jetzt ein Leerzeichen
oder zwei oder drei.
Da seht ihr, da sind da jetzt auch Leerzeichen drin.
Und wie können wir diese Leerzeichen zum Beispiel weglöschen?
Das kann man mit Strip machen.
Und dann werden euch diese Leerzeichen wieder gelöscht.
Und natürlich kann es sein,
dass eben die großen Kleinschreibungen nicht passen und so.
Und da kann man dann eben auch wieder
diese String-Methoden verwenden.
Die haben wir hier schon ein bisschen kennengelernt,
zum Beispiel Lower, Upper, Title.
Da kann man dann den Text in Kleinbuchstaben verwandeln,
in Großbuchstaben verwandeln
oder schauen, dass immer da erste Buchstabe großgeschrieben wird.
So zum Beispiel.
Zuerst löschen wir praktisch hier.
Die Leerzeichen müssen nicht nur vorne sein,
die können auch hinten sein.
Wenn sie dazwischen sein, werden sie aber nicht draus gelöscht.
Also sie werden nur mit Strip,
werden sie nur vorne und hinten gelöscht.
Da gibt es auch noch R-Strip oder L-Strip,
wo ihr dann an der rechten Stelle nur
oder an der linken Stelle nur weglöschen könnt.
Das könnt ihr dann selber ausprobieren.
Zum Casting.
Also wir haben ja jetzt das Problem,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
wenn wir hier eine Zahl haben,
also hier ein Integer,
und dann die zweite Zahl ist aber ein String.
Was passiert, wenn wir die zusammen addieren,
kann man einen Fehler.
Und da, falls ihr euch noch erinnern könnt,
eine vorherige Vorlesung,
da haben wir dieses Casting,
mit dem wir praktisch diesen String wieder umwandeln,
in etwas anderes,
zum Beispiel eben in ein Integer,
in ein Float, in ein Boolean,
oder eben auch,
kann man natürlich auch umgekehrt machen,
dass man eine Zahl in ein String umwandelt.
Genau, und da gibt es eben
viele verschiedenen Datentypen.
Das heißt, wir müssen zuerst casten,
bevor wir addieren.
Das können wir auch kurz ausprobieren.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt da 12,
plus das hier machen,
was passiert?
Wenn ich da 3 rein schreibe,
mag er nicht.
Da bekommen wir diesen Type-Error raus.
Praktisch die Datentypen
stimmen wir nicht miteinander ein.
Was machen wir?
Wir casten das Ganze einfach zu einem Integer,
und dann haben wir die Daten,
die wir in einem String haben,
und jetzt, wenn wir da 3 reinschreiben,
funktioniert so eine Probleme.
Natürlich,
wie gesagt, da gibt es wieder,
also das ist ja dann wieder Casting.
Das heißt, wenn wir da
4 und noch ein String dazuschreiben,
funktioniert unser Casting nicht mehr.
Was müssen wir da machen?
Da müssen wir zuerst
alles rauslöschen, was keine Zahl ist,
damit das funktioniert.
Und da gibt es natürlich auch wieder
Möglichkeiten, wie man das macht.
Ich bin uns nicht ganz sicher, ob das eine Aufgabe ist,
deshalb werde ich das jetzt nicht erwähnen,
falls ihr
da Probleme habt,
dann könnt ihr da immer noch
im Titel eine Frage stellen,
und ich werde euch das beantworten.